blue paper is the author of this book
Empire William s Paley and the making of
CBS for the next hour we will talk about
mr. Paley and his work on developing
Columbia Broadcasting System thanks for
joining us my pleasure
who is William Paley bill Paley was a
fortunate young man who happened to have
lucked out into buying a struggling
actually failing radio company in 1928
and through luck and skill and money
built it into the CBS empire when he
retired from CBS how successful was it
very successful when he retired well he
can't went retired came back from
retirement but by the time he left the
company in the late 1980s it was
obviously one of the three premiere
networks in the country when he took
when did he you said he got CBS in 1928
yes yes what happened was that there was
a company called United independent
broadcasters at the time there was one
only one other network which was NBC
which had been started by David Sarnoff
and tally heard about this opportunity
to buy into this struggling company and
so he went up he was a young man not
quite 27 years old he had a substantial
of money amount of money at his disposal
from his family and he was very excited
about the prospect of radio and so he
traveled from Philadelphia where he then
lived to New York and bought the company
and the rest I guess you could say his
history did Bill Perry have any
experience in broadcasting absolutely
not he came from a family that was
famous for making cigars and
unfortunately for his father who hoped
that his son would follow him in the
cigar business bill Paley
even as a young man wanted to have some
glamour in his life and wanted something
more entertaining than making and
selling cigars and he really thought
radio would be an avenue to find that
kind of life when he bought the company
did others
expect great success from him quite the
contrary I think a lot of people thought
it was a gamble that would not succeed
radio at the time was still a new
invention and the power that it has
today was not foreseen by most people
and I think people saw it as a gamble
that would soon bring him back to his
family's cigar business in Philadelphia
but of course things turned out
differently than those people had
expected we're talking with Lew paper he
was wrote in a book Empire William s
Paley and the making of CBS for the next
hour if you want to find out more about
bill Paley find out more about CBS you
have a number of lines to do so two oh
two five eight five three eight eight
zero our line for Republicans 202 585 3
881 our line for Democrats and for
everyone else - OH - 585 382 we also
have an international line available
that is 202 585 three eight eight three
let's go back to his early years you
said that he was expected to take over
in the family cigar business well that's
correct well at least to go into it and
ultimately take over the family cigar
business he was the only son he had a
sister and his father Sam was very
successful in the cigar business and one
of the things that bill Paley did when
he was working in the cigar business in
Philadelphia was to arrange for some
advertisements on a Philadelphia radio
station at the time his father and his
uncle who ran the business were very
much opposed to it but they could not
deny the fact that soon after the
advertisements ran people began to ask
about the programming and they began to
realize the power of radio and I'm sure
bill Paley also at that time I
appreciated the power of radio and I
think that helped to account for his
interest and taking advantage of this
opportunity to buy into this struggling
company in New York in 1928 when he
bought the company what are some of the
first things he's did as its boss well
the some of the first things he did was
to try and arrange for programming and
to fill up the time and that was a no
easy matter they used to have at that
time
programs that were completely sponsored
by advertisers and those were commercial
programming most of the programming
however was called sustaining
programming which meant programming that
could find no sponsor so in order to get
more advertisers the first thing that
bill Paley had to do was find affiliates
for his network which he renamed the
Columbia Broadcasting System and he the
first thing he did was to go out and try
to find other radio stations who would
affiliate with the struggling a new
radio network so that advertisers would
be attracted to advertise their wares
and products on his network is it fair
to say he's the father of the affiliate
system no I think no I don't think that
would be fair I think the affiliate
system was in place before he got there
NBC was already existing as a network I
think the only thing that he did was to
use his skills in business and
personality-wise to develop a very
successful competing Network because NBC
was there first but bill Paley and
people I think were skeptical as to
whether another radio network let alone
one radio that network could succeed and
I think people were doubtful that bill
Paley could take his company and compete
against NBC which was then owned by a
giant company called RCA and so I think
people were very skeptical and so I
think that bill Paley had to develop a
system but he's not the father of the
affiliate system we'll find out more
about bill Paley and CBS as we go along
first call this morning North Andover
Massachusetts on our line for others
hello well good morning and thank you
every show is totally informative I
thank you so much for c-span 2 points
for mr. paper first of all do you know
if there was any connection with mr.
Paley ever with man named
from from advertising for now
Bernays everyday Edward L Bernays yes
right exactly I'm sorry I said it wrong
that's okay and then the other question
was in the later part of his life do you
know if he was ever connected very much
with or knew Steve Ross who worked with
Luce and the connection with Time Warner
the conglomerate that became Time Warner
that was then taken over with Gerald
Levin with AOL because Steve Ross was
very big into Warner Brothers at the
beginning and I wondered if there was an
in connection with them because there
was also a underground connection I
believe with mafia money with with the
Rosses and all of the different things
in there I wondered if mr. Paley was
ever connected with that side of media
the paper well in terms of Edward
Bernays Edward Bernays is often called
in some circles the father of public
relations and he was active in the first
part of the 20th century and yes bill
Paley did have a relationship with
Edward Bernays because bill Paley
recognized that one of the things he
needed in order to make his network
successful was good public relations and
for that
Paley's father had instructed him to
seek out the best and whatever skill or
service he needed and Edward Bernays was
at the top of his field and Edie and
bill Paley did rely on him and did
retain him and ironically Edward Bernays
ultimately recommended that Paley hire a
person named Edward Klauber
saying that Paley needed an assistant
like Klauber to help him handle the
variety of tasks that you have when you
run a network and one of the first
things that Klauber did ironically when
he came on to Paley's employ was to fire
Edward Bernays saying they no longer
needed him so I guess Edward Bernays
learned the risks of making
recommendations for employment
with respect to Steve Ross Pelle of
course did know Steve Rossi was married
to his daughter Amanda a stepdaughter
Amanda and so he did know Steve Ross I
am not aware and never came across in my
research however any information or even
a suggestion that Paley was in any way
connected with a mafia or the mob or
anything of that nature
on our line for Democrats Richmond
Virginia
go ahead hello go ahead good morning my
name is Hal Brown and I had a question
on the brand of cigars that mr. Bailey's
family owned could you give me that I
believe the cigar brand was La polina
which was obviously take on the name of
Paley and in fact one of the first
programs that they sponsored on that
Philadelphia radio station that I
mentioned a few moments ago was called
La Polina our and when the program aired
and then they decided the bill Paley's
father and uncle decided to discontinue
the advertisement or the programming
people kept asking what happened to La
Polina our and it was then that they
began to realize the power of radio
don't parently made that was one to make
a transition from advertiser own
programs to programs that CBS would own
right why what encouraged that changed
in terms of that was done because Paley
realized that unless the network
controlled the programming that there
were too many problems that could arise
one thing Paley did not like was
controversy and if he turned over the
control of a programming to an
advertiser then the network could
experience and suffer the risks of any
controversy that that program
programming generated and in the 1930s
for example there were some programs
that were sold to some religious groups
and those religious groups in turn had
some people who had some very
controversial
view views about how to handle the
depression and so sometimes people saw
the programming on CBS and so when
people complained they complained the
CBS and bill Paley did not like that he
did not like controversy and he felt the
best way to limit and hopefully avoid
controversy was for CBS to have complete
control over its programming that is the
New Jersey on our line for others go
ahead
good morning c-span and good morning mr.
paper my question pertains to Paley and
cable in the back of my mind I seem to
have a recollection that the Paley
started some kind of arts cable channel
that didn't work and ultimately failed
and I'm curious it seemed to me or it
seems to me that a more logical fit
would have been a news channel on cable
because of the preeminence of CBS News
I'm just wondering if that was ever
considered and if it was how come it
wasn't pursued well you're quite right
Paley did have an interest in developing
a cable channel and in the early 1980s
and the cable channel that he envisioned
was one that would focus on cultural
events symphonies and plays and things
that most people might consider to be
highbrow or very cultured that would not
find a mass audience on television and
Paley wanted to pursue that on cable
instead of news because he saw cable as
providing an opportunity for what I
would call niche programming and thought
that with cable you did not have to
worry about attracting the mass
audiences that were required to support
a network television program and so for
that reason he tried to develop this
cultural channel on cable cultural
channel but he was really quite frankly
a little bit ahead of his time he tried
to do it in the early 1980s and he had
hoped that he could attract advertiser
support for that but it just wasn't
there Cable had not penetrated American
homes to the extent that has now it was
only in passing about a third or a
quarter of the American homes and they
simply could not find the advertisers
who would support what was then the
enormous expense
that cable channel in terms of news I
think that ple didn't consider a news
cable channel because at the time we had
CBS which was in many respects regarded
as the premier news network
and I don't think he wanted to do
anything at that time that would compete
with his own network things are a little
different today but at that time in the
early 1980s I think Paley just saw a
news cable channel as something that
would simply detract from the audience
he wanted to attract for his network
television programming if you want to
find out more about bill Paley asked
questions of our guest loo paper three
lines you can call in on your screen
there 585 three eight eight zero our
line for Republicans five eight five
three eight a one-hour line for
Democrats our line for others five eight
five three eight eight to all of those
begin with - OH - when did CBS make the
jump in the television well CBS really
started to experiment with television in
the 1930s and that progressed through
the 1940s the problem was in
experimenting with it with the
technology
there was really no audience out there
yet because people were not buying
television sets the jump real jump the
television came after World War two
because then the technology had been
refined and people were starting
companies were starting to manufacture
and sell TV sets and as a result of that
you could really develop programming and
hopefully find an audience when did he
add uses a television use as a component
of the network and again right after you
know the nineteen World War two is when
they really started to focus on
providing news on television now prior
to that news had been a premiere a basic
element of the radio network and
everybody of course would remember
Edward or Murrow but Edward or amuro's
fame came over radio not over television
and but it was after World War two that
he made the transition along with a lot
of the other people who had made their
success in news on radio
were switched over to television besides
Murrow who else did he recruited as
big-time names for his news programming
well the news programming had a host of
people who were then considered stars
you had Charles Collingwood Eric
severide Walter Cronkite came on Walter
Cronkite actually came on and really
came on in television in 1950 I believe
it was
but you had Schoenbrunn and numerous
other people like that Winston Burdette
there were a host of people who worked
with William shire was another one who
worked with Murrow primarily in Europe
because everybody was focused obviously
during the war on news from abroad and
people like Murrow who would stand on
rooftops in London and provide an
eyewitness account of the blitzkrieg
over London attracted a lot of worldwide
attention on our line for Democrats
Lincoln Park New Jersey for Lew paper
good morning thank you for c-span Pablo
it's good to see you in the anchors seat
good morning sir I have several quests
two quick questions and a comment of
concerning mr. Paley I understand from a
personal from personal knowledge that he
is a very hands-on executive an engineer
who transmitted I believe at that time
from the Empire State Building said he
actually would go up and visit his
engineers and check out transmissions I
wanted to know if you had any knowledge
of that my second question is that who
would you consider Kelley's counterpart
in the media today would it be Ted
Turner Bloomberg or maybe someone else
you know and thirdly I've read some in
mainly in which you would call ladies
magazines for example vogue etc there
have been some unflattering accounts of
mr. Pelley's personal life his wife was
always considered very attractive and
constantly on the best-dressed lists etc
how much of that is true and one quick
thing in closing and I'll listen to the
gentleman sir
response is that I really was upset
about the woman who claimed mafia money
I find that very discriminatory this in
high business and on my experience has
been in the corporate sector the deals
are made all the time to label anything
mafia money is blatantly discriminatory
and I really wish that people would get
over this Godfather mentality or anyone
whose name ends with the vowel etc and
that's I hope you understand but now
I'll wait to him mr. papers comments
thank you well I'll leave aside that
last comment and let the audience be the
judge of that but with respect to the
three questions you asked the first one
concerns Paley's hands on attitude and
his inspection of engineering facilities
when he first took over the network on
the 20s and through the 30s and I guess
through the beginning of the 40s but
Paley was a hands-on person who did want
to look at equipment did want to look at
the transmission facilities and was very
interested in that because again CBS was
the junior network it was struggling to
keep up and hopefully surpassed NBC and
it was all new not only to the country
but also to bill Paley and bill Paley
wanted to be successful and he knew that
in order to be successful at least in
the beginning he had to pay attention to
what was going on so your comment about
him going on to inspect transmission
facilities and matters of that kind is
certainly true in terms of who would be
bill Paley's counterpart today is really
a difficult question to answer when bill
Paley came on to and and bought United
independent broadcasters and created a
CBS in 1928 there was really no one
around there was other than NBC and
radio was a new
adventure so to speak for the country
and so today the world is completely
different and broadcasting has become a
very powerful instrument and there's no
one today who would doubt its power
however I think if you would liken him
to anybody today I think I would have to
it would have to be in my mind Rupert
Murdoch because for so many years so
many people said that there could never
be any more than three networks there
was ABC NBC and CBS and the notion that
somebody could create a successful
fourth network was looked at as a fool's
errand and Rupert Murdoch proved them
wrong and I think to that extent in the
same way that bill Paley proved his
critics wrong when he made CBS a success
I think you can say that Rupert Murdoch
proved the world wrong again or the
broadcast industry wrong again by
creating what has become certainly a
very successful fourth network in terms
of Paley's personal life it really was
extraordinary and probably something
that very few people could comprehend
certainly a very very few people could
share the same experience bill Paley was
wealthy beyond anybody's comprehension
he was a multimillionaire
millionaire several times over by 1930
at a time when most of the country was
sunk and depression bill Paley was
making millions of dollars and he beyond
having the money he wanted to enjoy he
came from a family of wealth and he was
always dedicated to enjoying every
aspect of life I think one of the things
that characterizes and distinguishes
bill Paley from people a lot of people
in the event was he wanted to make sure
that he enjoyed life to the fullest he
had a real zest for life whether it be
food women houses theater whatever it
was he was interested in experiencing at
all and having it all how many times was
William Paley married he was married
twice he was married first to Dorothy
Hart
believed that marriage was in 1930 and
then he was married married to Bailey
and and he married her I believe in 1947
did he have children he had children he
had actually if he counts stepchildren
he had six children Bailey had two
children who became part of the family
he and babe had two children and then he
had two children with Dorothy so there
were six children in all none of whom to
my knowledge is involved in broadcasting
Washington DC up next on our line for
Democrats hello go ahead hi hello what
was William Paley's relationship with
President Roosevelt and and the
Roosevelt family families actually had a
good relationship with Franklin
Roosevelt it wasn't a deep relationship
by any means Paley as base was basically
an apolitical person but there were
times when he had contact with Roosevelt
for example there was a time when
apparently was trying to establish a
radio network in Latin America and he
got a call from the White House asking
him to come see Franklin Roosevelt to
discuss it because Roosevelt was
concerned about Nazi penetration in
Latin America and was hopeful that Paley
could use his trip to provide some
insight into the state of affairs at
least with respect to Nazi penetration
in Latin America Paley also was
interested in contacting Roosevelt
because in the 1930s there was a lot of
activity at the Federal Communications
Commission which regulates broadcasting
and Paley was on numerous occasions
trying to seek Roosevelt's help and
helped helping helping to CBS to deal
with a lot of the problems that he
foresaw with the FCC's regulation of
broadcasting Henley also served under a
commission for President Truman he did
Paley was president chairman of the
president's materials policy commit
in 1952 and that was a commission that
was designed to look at resource
shortages in the country and he was the
chairman of that Commission it was a
Presidential Commission and
interestingly enough one of the things
that pallies Commission forecast was
that unless the country did something
that within the next quarter century the
country would experience a shortage in
energy and oil and ironically of course
that is precisely what happened now
having said that I don't think Paley can
take all the credit for that that
prediction or forecast was really based
upon the executive director and the
various other experts that they had
working for the Commission but certainly
that was one of the products of that
commission going back in history a
little bit you made a comment about the
cigar company barber green and Phoenix
writes that the reason the cigars were
called la polina is because their house
was on the corner of Laramie and pilita
in Chicago
my mother was bill Paley's first cousin
and grew up there four brothers started
the Congress cigar company the lady on
the box was Bill's mother Goldie mm-hmm
well that may be right you never know
when bill Paley took over CBS when did
he add entertainment as a division for
the network well I don't know if it
became a separate division but from the
very beginning Paley was concerned about
entertainment one of the things that he
noticed anu was that NBC had generally
speaking superior technical facilities
in its radio stations but bill Paley
recognized that it did not matter if you
had technical but better technical
facilities if the programming was not
appreciated by the audience so he really
focused on programming because he said
you could have the most resplendent
movie theater in the world but if it's
not playing the movies that people want
to see it won't matter so he really
sought to build up the entertainment
side of CBS the one thing that he
noticed and did was that a lot of the
first stars in entertainment on radio
were
at NBC and so parently again not wanting
to take risks did everything he could to
attract a lot of those stars at NBC and
bring them over to CBS some of the
people that he was successful in
bringing over from NBC to CBS included
Jack Benny and George Burns and Gracie
Allen some other names include Jackie
Gleason
now Jackie Gleason that was in primary
and television primarily Jackie Gleason
he did Jackie Gleason was a star with
the Dumont television network for people
who might remember that in the early
1950s and Paley was very impressed with
Jackie Gleason and brought him on to CBS
in fact there was a very entertaining
story that Gleason told me which was
that when they were trying to negotiate
the contract with Gleason Gleason was a
heavy drinker and Gleason and his agent
went over to visit with Paley at Paley's
offices at CBS and the head of the
programming department at CBS and
Gleason was suffering from a hangover
and while they're discussing tossing
around these big numbers as to what
Gleason wants and what CBS wanted to
give him which was obviously less than
what Gleason wanted Gleason still
suffering from that hangover fell asleep
in the middle of the negotiations and
Paley looked over to his counterpart and
said if that's the way he feels you
better give him the money
Boca Raton Florida up next on our line
brothers morning mr. paper I was hoping
you could talk a little bit about
William Paley and his relationship with
Edward Armour Oh at the end if you read
the friendly book and the Murrow book
you kind of get the impression there was
a either a love-hate relationship
between Paley and Murrow or mr. Paley
definitely was responding to government
pressure to limit how controversial the
Murrow shows were getting and I was just
wondering if you could talk about his
relationship with the government
especially during the fifties I'll take
the answer right here with Pamela's
relationship with the government with
Paley's relationship with the government
was
obviously his company was regulated in
many respects by the Federal
Communication Commission and there was
evidence that ple did cooperate with the
CIA and the FBI in the 1950s in terms of
providing them access to reporters and
some company resources and helping them
deal with you might call the Communist
Menace which was then overriding
everything in the 1950s and there's also
no question although I it was not from
any direct government intervention
there's no question that CBS
participated in the widespread practice
of blacklisting in the 1950s and that
certainly was not one of CBS's or Bill
Paley's proudest moments but there were
people who were tainted with the tag of
communism and could not find work on CBS
or many other networks because of that
tag arlington virginia on our line for
democrats go ahead please hi how are you
great you this came and said this
discussion of william s apparently came
it's a very timely discussion I believe
I've always been curious about
syndication and radio and the way radio
entertainment has been coming to I guess
into its own I guess over the last ten
years or so since talk radio has become
I think since the first Gulf War talk
radio has become increasingly more
popular but it's talk news oriented if
you know what I mean so it's not just
music it's not just DJs and it's also
not just news reporting so it's a
combination of the two now where do you
mess parently I think being a pioneer in
the blending of the two I think it's
interesting that CBS of all
conglomerates are now really in the
forefront of putting this type of
entertainment together on the radio for
example if you are in the Washington DC
area like for example the Don and Mike
show which is on like I guess lunchtime
drive time they have a newsman named
buzz Burbank who I would I would
probably compare it to Edward are Murrow
myself but the show itself
I think like kicks ass in the ratings
and if it were not for the Donna Mike
show I probably wouldn't be calling you
right now to go no paper well I'm not
sure if you're asking me what pill bill
Paley would think of a talk radio I
think he would do whatever was necessary
to get ratings because he was interested
in success more than anything else and
giving people within certain parameters
of taste and legality what they wanted
and in radio he tried to give people
what they wanted in terms of
entertainment and in terms of news and
that carried over when it came to
television but in all of this especially
as the company got bigger and more
successful what happened at that point
was Paley took a step back and he
delegated authority to a lot of people
and so that a program like all in the
family which Paley hated because it was
so vulgar in his mind and so
antithetical to his notions of culture
and taste but he went along with it
because the programming staff at CBS
felt it would be successful and they
were dedicated to it and he was willing
to go along with his staff Kingsport
Tennessee on our line for others yes I
wonder if mr. paper would agree that
bill Paley made Lyndon Johnson wealthy
and in doing so probably was a big
factor in furthering his political
career
oh hang up Thank You caller what makes
you say that
he made the Lyndon Johnson wealthy let
the paper knows that Lyndon Johnson came
to Paley and one of our little radio
station down in Austin or had bought one
and mr. Paley hooked him up to the CBS
network new paper well I think that's
absolutely correct
bill Paley did help Lyndon Johnson in
many respects because Lyndon Johnson did
have this little station in Austin Texas
and it did become a CBS affiliate
interestingly enough Lyndon Johnson's
primary relationship was really with
Frank Stanton who is the longtime
president of CBS and before that the
head of research and that was where the
relationship really existed but there's
no question that bill Paley was
beneficial to Lyndon Johnson's ability
to make money we're talking with Lew
paper he is the author of a book on
William s Paley we're talking about
William s belly for the next 25 minutes
our next call is from South Kingstown
Rhode Island on our line for Republicans
hello go ahead I would just like you to
elaborate on Bill Paley's relationship
with David Sarnoff if there was one and
I'll hang up and listen thank you bill
Paley certainly had a relationship with
David Sarnoff David Sarnoff was
certainly viewed in the beginning before
bill Paley got there as the king of
radio David Sarnoff was the one who
really developed or was instrumental and
pushing for the development of a a mass
system of radio and he was the one who
ultimately headed up the NBC network
that was in existence when Paley bought
this interest in United independent
broadcasters in 1928 and there being
only two networks at the time the two
work competed competitors had many
conversations about many topics from
programming to television sets to FCC
regulations and I think that there was a
in some respects a grudging respect that
they each gave to each other each had
been successful in his own right the
difference between them however was very
dramatic bill Paley was a person who was
very interested in programming and he
spent a lot of time courting and
developing and being with people who
appeared on the radio in and on
television whether it be news people or
whether it be entertainers David Sarnoff
did not have that Flair or interest for
programming
that Paley did and one of the reasons
that Paley was so successful in getting
a lot of the stars at NBC to come over
to CBS in addition to money of course
was the fact that Sarnoff did not
cultivate the relationships with
performers and news people the way bill
Paley did Chicago Illinois on our line
for Democrats hi um I will reading your
book in high school and I was just
wondering if you look do you think pay
label at the last few years of his life
regretted affiliating himself with
Lawrence Tisch considering that was
about the time when the ratings for CBS
began to slip both some news and M
programming and what is was his
relationship with is that with the
anchorman of both Walter Cronkite and
Dan Rather well with respect to Larry
Tisch I think there are two sides to
that question first of all there is no
question that bill Paley had to be very
thankful and appreciative Larry Tisch
coming along because bill Paley had been
forced to retire in 1983 as chairman of
the board from CBS and Tom Wyman came in
and Paley did not like being retired
even though he was then in his 80s
Larry Tisch came along and Larry Tisch
provided Paley with an opportunity to
come out of retirement and to become the
CBS chairman again and that was
something that Paley was delighted to do
and for which he had to be very grateful
at the same time bill Paley had his own
views as to how the company should be
run nobody could run the company in his
mind the way he could run it and so
therefore when Larry Tisch began to make
changes I think there were many changes
that were made in programming and
elsewhere that bill Paley had second
thoughts about because again he would
have done it differently so in terms of
Tisch I think it was a double-edged
sword
why did Paley choose Larry
tsch to run the company well it wasn't a
question of Larry
bill Paley choosing Larry Tish it was
really Larry Tish choosing bill Paley
because what had happened was that Ted
Turner had made an overture to by CBS
stock and take over the company and
although he was in retirement bill Paley
was appalled at the notion that Ted
Turner would take over CBS and so there
were quite a number of discussions about
how to prevent Ted Turner from taking
over CBS and suddenly Larry Tisch who
had access to a lot of resources came on
as a white knight Larry
Tisch had a relationship with one of the
board members on CBS and made known his
interest in trying to help fend off this
takeover attempt by Ted Turner and so
Larry tissue wound up buying CBS stock
and ultimately became CBS's largest
stockholder eclipsing the amount of
stock held by Bill Paley and his family
and so the ownership of that stock gave
Larry Tisch a lot of power we've been
looking at media leaders on Sunday next
week we will profile Ted Turner at this
time next Sunday our next call is from
New York City on our line for
Republicans hi hi go ahead I think I
just heard you say that next week you'll
be profiling Ted Turner yes I can't wait
for that show because what a nut he is
but anyway the reason I'm calling is to
ask you if the week the sensationalism
in media and news reporting and
entertainment are these days everything
is almost like a panic where they want
you to feel nervous they want you to be
not that they want you to anticipate the
program but they want you to be nervous
that we're all about to die do you think
if William s Paley was alive today that
he would be listening to the Don and
Mike show and I think we got caught off
here well with Paley listen to the Donna
Mike show I'm not sure if he would be
listening to it and as I mentioned
before Paley's interest was not in
picking programs that he necessarily
liked so much in picking programs that
would fit within his idea of what was
appropriate for his network and also
programs that would make have high
ratings and make a
of money as I mentioned all in the
family was a classic example of a
program that Paley found very upsetting
because it used epithets abused vulgar
language there were many scenes
involving sexual nuances that pally
thought were really beyond the pale
because we're talking about a time when
there had not yet reached a television
the kind of sexual license that you see
on television today but again he went
ahead with all on the family because the
staff was convinced that it was
necessary to have programming like that
to stay in the parade and Paley wanted
to be in the parade he wanted to have a
successful Network and if he thought
that Don and Mike would be a successful
program I think he would go along with
it I even think he probably would go
along with Howard Stern for the same
reason our next call Indianapolis
Indiana on our line for others hello
hello mr. paper very interesting
discussion you didn't mention one of the
stars of CBS radio that they stole from
NBC was Amos and Andy
Charles Carell and the the other
gentlemen a show that ran for 20 or more
years was always in the top ten and then
moved over to television and created a
controversy that still lasts to this day
would you explain why this show is still
banned from television wasn't even
mentioned on the 75th anniversary of NBC
recently except to show just a brief
scene of the TV stars well you're quite
right again this was part of what they
sometimes called the Paley raids in the
I guess mid-40s right after world war ii
when Paley decided that he had to gear
up for television he saw television
coming and he saw also that there was a
need to bulk up in programming generally
an entertainment programming and again
he saw that a lot of the successful
programmers were at NBC and so for Paley
he didn't want to take any risks he
wanted whatever worked and he saw that a
lot of these entertainers worked and one
programming
program that did work was as you say
Amos and Andy and he had been after them
for years to try and persuade them to
come over to CBS what ultimately
persuaded them again was as I mentioned
before CBS was willing to offer a
package of money that made it very
profitable for them to make the switch
and also Paley courted them and gave
them the kind of attention that David
Sarnoff never did and so and as you say
that kind of programming still generates
a lot of controversy for obvious reasons
but at the time it was certainly
acceptable and very successful what was
the controversy surrounding Amos
somebody had two white gentlemen
portraying two black people and and
really providing stereotyped images of
how black people would interact and I
think today nobody would do that on our
line for Democrats Boston Massachusetts
go ahead
I'd like to know how they Paley played a
role in his success her style she was so
glamorous or her whole aura did this
help him I would say it certainly did
not help him in his business bill Paley
kept for the most part his business life
and his family life very separate and so
there are very few discussions with his
family about what was going on in
business and there was no instance that
I could see where Bay Paley played any
real role in any decisions bill Paley
made as a broadcast executive she did
give him an allure and a picture of
being part of society high society but
he also had that in his own right he had
been married to Dorothy Hart before that
and so but baby Paley certainly enhanced
his image in the press there's no
question about that the only thing that
is interesting notwithstanding Paley's
general separation of business and
family life was that at one point he
mentioned to me that he felt very
disappointed about his selection of Tom
Wyman in 1980
as his successor and by that time Bailey
had died from lung cancer and he said to
me that he felt that he would never have
chosen Wyman if his wife had been around
because he said that women have are much
better judge of people than men
at least in his view I think although he
did say that I think the story's a
little apocryphal because again I'm not
sure that bill Paley was consulting with
his wife about who and paths to select
as a successor but that is what he said
and how long was he married to his first
wife he was married to Dorothy hard for
about 17 years they got married I
believe in 1930 and they got the worst
in 1946 1947 shortly after the war Oak
Park Illinois and are lying for others
yes could the speaker elaborate on
Bailey's origin development and
education in Chicago and when and why
did you move to New York well he was in
Chicago because that's where his family
was and his family was a Jewish Eastern
European origin they moved to
Philadelphia of the family was moved
there because of business reasons that's
where Sam pally
Bailey's father took his business and so
that's why he went there and he went to
New York ultimately because United
independent broadcasters the company
that he bought in bought an interest in
in 1928 was located in New York and
beyond that I think Paoli was very
interested in going to New York because
there's no place like New York City and
New York City held the promise of a much
more glamorous life at least in Paley's
mind than he could find in Philadelphia
what was the relationship with his
parents family's relationship with his
parents was mixed I think that with
respect to his father I think he had a
very close relationship with his father
and throughout their entire life Sanpei
I used to call Bill Willy and he groomed
him to be a good businessman hopefully
somebody who would take over his
leadership and the cigar business but
who stayed with Paley and became a
director at CBS and even when bill Paley
was a powerful broadcast executive and
Sam Paley who was in his 80s would come
to the board meetings Paley would always
get up give his father a warm embrace
and a kiss and it was very clear that
they held a lot of affection for each
other with respect to his mother I think
the relationship was not quite the same
I think Paley always had a nagging sense
that his mother liked his sister more
and there was a certain distance between
bill Paley and his mother and his sister
and he did not have the same kind of
warmth and affectionate relationship
that he had with his father Newark New
Jersey on our line from Republicans I my
question is at what point did you hear
that did he like the power brokers that
be in charge of the network's turned the
power over to boards of directors with
the exception of saying Michael Eisner
today you never really hear the name of
the person in charge of the network with
few exceptions like for example you have
a michael eisner in charge of Disney and
you have Michael Mehra's taint in charge
of the Don and might show well I think
the times were different you have to
remember again that when Paley came on
to the scene in broadcasting in 1928 it
was a new venture and he did everything
and he oversaw everything and so it was
his company and he was clearly
identified with a company and although
they would have a Board of Directors the
Board of Directors was completely
dominated by Paley through his ownership
of stock as well as through his
management his detailed management of
the company and he controlled all the
employees today in this era of
consolidation things have dramatically
changed CBS is not a standalone entity
the way it once was and so therefore
what you have is a change in the
corporate structure not only in
broadcasting but throughout America that
reflects as I say the consolidation
and results in Board of Directors
appearing to have more power than one
individual what the bill Paley do after
his retirement well when you say I after
his retirement he really retired was
forced a retire to retire as chairman in
1983 and he tried to keep himself busy
with various ventures because he wanted
to stay active he had the Broadcasting
Museum which he helped found and was
located in New York City he undertook
various experiments and not experiments
but ventures into new fields such as
artificial intelligence and he tried to
do other things of that kind he became
active in some activities in Israel and
sponsored something actually on behalf
or in memory of his mother but he was
only in retirement for about three years
before Larry Tisch came along and asked
him to return as chairman of the board
and what was his role after he came back
well when he came back he was chairman
of the board but at that point he was 85
years old and Larry Tisch was really the
power behind the throne so to speak or
maybe the power in the throne and Paley
had only I think a symbolic involvement
with the company at that point on our
line for others Santa Maria California
hello go ahead I can't hear any more so
it's hard to talk i I knew Dorothy Hart
as a child I want met her when I was in
sixth grade and she was in fifth grade
you said she got married in 1930 well I
didn't get married until 1944 and I was
23 at that time so she must have been a
child bride I don't know I remember she
went to New York and and we kept in
touch for some years and she was a in I
don't know movies or theater or
something
can you elaborate any more about her
life with him and I listened that's fine
she I think Dorothy Hart actually was
married if I recall correctly to jack
Hearst who
was one of the sons of William Randolph
Hearst and she actually met bill Paley
at a party in one of these fashionable
homes in the North Shore of Long Island
and they began to have an affair and she
divorced jack Hearst and married bill
Paley and she was a very classy woman
and had was very active in democratic
politics and kept in fact voice I was
voicing might be the wrong word but
certainly pushing her opinions on Paley
who was very apolitical but she was one
of the people who was a great fan of
Franklin Roosevelt and encouraged her
husband to develop a relationship with
the president why did you write a book
about William Paley I wrote a book about
bill Paley because I'm a lawyer involved
in broadcasting and I'm a communications
lawyer and when I started this book in
1984 the only real biography out there
about bill Paley was his 1979
autobiography and it seemed to me that
the time was ripe to have an
autobiography he was clearly one of the
Giants of the broadcast industry and I
thought that there might be some value
in exploring his life and how he built
CBS and his impact on broadcasting did
you have a chance to interview him
directly yes I did I talked to him a lot
to a lot of his people and had an
opportunity to talk to him actually have
lunch with him over at black rock which
was CBS headquarters and also to talk
with him afterwards and and his staff
although this was not in any sense an
authorized biography and in fact I think
he resisted it but they were generally
helpful in providing information and
checking facts as I progressed how long
did it take you to compile the book it
took about three years from start to
finish three or four years from start to
finish for me to do the book McClane
Virginia on our line for others go ahead
please
yes I'm mr. Bailey's grandchild caller
could you turn down your TV please yeah
I will I I'm called well I think you
probably answered my question one of the
reasons I was calling was to ask the
author's motivation and writing a book
but I also detected in the beginning of
this program a slight sort of feeling of
sort of almost disrespect and I wondered
if he could elaborate on that he his
suggestion in the beginning that you
know that this company was founded and
he was extremely lucky and everything he
did it does belittle a little bit that
the legacy that he did create and I just
wanted to say that he was a wonderful
grandfather and he provided extreme
insight for my life and and I as a
person I just would like to say on
record that he was he was very very
special well I certainly did not mean
any disrespect to bill Paley and if I
said the reference to luck the fact is
that he did have some luck and sometimes
our opportunities our luck are created
by people who pursue things but there
was no intent on my part to convey any
sense of disrespect to the contrary I
think bill Paley is one of the Giants
and the history of broadcasting I think
he's probably all things considered the
single most important person in shaping
what broadcasting ultimately became
because at the time when he took over
the only other person of comparable
somebody who could be considered a peer
was David Sarnoff and David Sarnoff as I
mentioned did not have Paley's Flair or
interest in programming and a lot of the
standards for both news and
entertainment programming were shaped by
bill Paley so I think and and I will
tell you that my impression from the
contact I had with
was also very positive and I can
understand why you say that that you
found them to be a warm person the charm
was one of Bill Paley's great attributes
and I'm sure he used it in his personal
and social life and it was also
something that was very useful to him in
building CBS because he could use that
charm in getting people to do what he
wanted and in attracting both news
people and entertainment field people to
CBS lou paper is the author of empire
william s Paley and the making of CBS we
thank you for joining us thank you very
much